David Cutler and professor of economics
at Harvard
I think of what reform has to accomplish
as three things when is it has to cover
everybody both for moral reasons as well
as economic reasons it's untenable to be
in a society where any change in your
circumstance like for example a
recession can mean you're out of the
health care system second is it has to
modernize the health care system so that
we really get money for what we put into
it we really get value for what we put
into it the misconception that you
referenced is that the idea the goal is
to save money the goal is not to save
money the goal is to do things where
they're appropriate and not do them
where they're not appropriate which is a
way of looking at it that's much more
consistent with where people are and the
values that we have and then the third
thing that we need in reform is we need
a public health system that actually
works to keep us healthy to keep us safe
that reinforces our medical care system
from things like h1n1 flu avian flu to
food and water safety to obesity and
smoking cessation
what people need to understand about
healthcare reform is that we can improve
the quality of care and lower spending
at the same time think about those
patients with chronic disease who are
not getting treated appropriately treat
them more appropriately they don't go
into the hospital they spend less and
their quality of life their length of
life is increased that's what we can do
if we really do it right so yes we need
to save money but we will save money as
a byproduct of having a system that
works better we're not going to save
money by taking a meat axe and just
Klein off some part of health care
spending that's what a lot of the
alternative is if we don't do this
what's going to happen probably a lot of
employers will just say hey you know
what we're just going to stick you in a
health plan with very high cost share
you go out and deal with it everything
we know is that people will stop taking
their medications they'll save money and
their health will deteriorate we have to
find a way and we believe there are ways
where we can save money and we can
improve health and people know this
people know that the health care system
costs more than it should and a part of
that is because the thing just doesn't
work right and you wind up having people
in very expensive circumstances after
the fact when you could have prevented
it so I don't think that convincing
people of that presumption is that hard
I think what we have to do is one make
sure we do that make sure we put the
steps in place to do that and second is
we need to make sure we don't demagogue
it so we just say to people oh what the
president wants is to ration your care
or what senator Kennedy wants is to make
sure you don't get so we need to get
away from that because people without
it's complicated enough no one's going
to understand all the details and if
people hear those things and they get
scared then they'll be tempted to back
off and that would be just the worst of
all situations
I mean give you three examples of why we
have waste and how you could get rid of
them the first example is look at what
actual providers are doing on a
moment-to-moment basis so if you people
done studies where you follow nurses in
a hospital with stopwatches or you have
them carry a Palm Pilot that where they
record everything that they do the most
common thing that a nurse in a hospital
does is document things she takes the
printouts from electrical equipment gets
it on paper re-enters it into a computer
that's a third of the time that doesn't
need to happen know whether industry
does that that's probably 30 billion
dollars a year spent on that so that's
one example and there are all sorts of
other examples ranging from infections
that are not prevented and so driving up
spending two doctors who spend 70
thousand dollars a year on the telephone
with insurance companies and pharmacies
and their staff doing that so the first
item is just money spent doing things
that in no other industry do we tolerate
which is why productivity is very low in
healthcare you can get rid of that with
information technology both what we have
and what we can expect in a reasonably
near future you could get rid of that
with payment changes you can get rid of
that through organizational changes the
second area is insurance companies that
drive up spending a lot by separating
out who's healthy and who's sick so they
spend a lot of money figuring out who
the healthy people are and who the sick
people are and how to ensure only the
healthy people that is a big big loss
for society of course someone has to pay
for the sick people they're not going to
pay for hundreds of thousands of dollars
on their own so me and you are going to
pay for it through tax dollars or
through other programs the money spent
shuffling them around is just a complete
waste and many of the insurance
companies recognize this and are willing
to do something about it so that's the
second example the third example is
people who have more very acute episodes
than they need to
when they have those episodes they cost
more than they should an example
diabetic patients who are not treated
well on an outpatient basis wind up
going into the hospital with kidney
failure in need of amputations of
extremities going blind with heart
attacks why because we couldn't get it
together to treat them better when they
were when they had diabetes without
those complications and then when they
have the complications of course we
don't manage it very well they go in the
hospital that come out of the hospital
they don't get a doctor's appointment
they don't see the nurse right away they
wind up coming back into the hospital
three weeks later with further
complications all of that is expensed
that doesn't need to happen and if we do
a better job coordinating care for
people better job managing them when
they're in less acute States better job
of dealing with them throughout the
course of their illness rather than just
at the very end we can save an enormous
amount of that expense as well
health care is the most information
intensive industry in the economy and it
uses information technology the least of
any industry in the economy so if you
think about where do we need information
to most it's clearly health care you
need to know what's going on with the
patient what they're allergic to what
kinds of issues they have what treatment
options and yet we still do things by
paper and pencil storing things in huge
stacks where you can't retrieve them and
they're not there where you need them
health care is amongst the lowest
productivity industries in the economy
if you look at the well performing
industries they tend to have three
features the productive industry scent
of three features first they use
information technology a lot they know
who's doing what why they're doing it
how rapidly they're doing it what the
outcome is how to improve it they're
always thinking about that there is
information technology a lot healthcare
we don't second they have compensation
arrangements that are tied to improving
value when employees create value they
get paid more when when they do things
that don't create value they don't get
paid as much in healthcare you get paid
for doing things for volume but not for
value and third is they they
decentralize it so that changes are made
by workers workers have authority the
famous Toyota model any worker can stop
the production line why because he or
she has the right information and the
right incentives to make sure that the
cars are coming out with the quality
that they need to in health care the
frontline workers are so busy just
getting by that they don't have the
opportunity to do better if you take
those nurses who are spending a third of
their time documenting things and say
well couldn't we do better they'd say
yes but I just don't have the time to
figure out how I'm so rushed I can't
figure it out Healthcare has got to get
better it's got to get better on the
information end where we've made a good
start with the recent American Recovery
and Reinvestment Act which is spending
30 billion dollars on health IT
compensation changes which you need to
follow that hopefully in health care
legislation that comes this fall that
will say we pay more for value and not
just for volume an organizational
changes freeing up organization
and helping them learn from each other
so that they say hey you know what I
really can read this a high-performing
enterprise this doesn't have to be an
enterprise that's got low productivity
come back to the most productive
businesses the ones that have
increasingly lower costs those are
businesses that are actually the most
innovative not the least innovative if
you look at the most productive
industries in the economy their
industries like information technology
like retail trade like agriculture that
use technology than most but they
directed the right way for people to
think that healthcare reform is going to
involve stifling innovation is just
absolutely wrong if we do it right we're
going to open the possibilities for
enormous amount of innovation it just
give you a different example than what
we've seen take them take that
antidepressant drugs just this one
example it is a well-known fact that
antidepressant drugs the same drug will
work on some patients and not work on
others is give give people paxil or give
people prozac or give them celexa or
whatever it is some patients respond to
it other patients don't and it's
different some people respond to one
medication some people respond to
another some people respond to a third
but not to the others why is that well
we don't know there's surely something
biological about it when you switch
people from one drug to another you do
wind up sometimes getting them to
respondent getting better well with a
little bit of innovation will be able to
figure out which patients will respond
better to which drugs as a result we can
avoid giving people drugs are not going
to respond to wasting money wasting
treatment the people don't come back
because the thing is not working even
worse with some kind of chemotherapy
agents where the patient dies in the
interim with innovation will be able to
figure out how to tailor what you need
what you get to what you need in
addition to all the other things we're
talking about so we'll have a medical
care system that's actually customized
for you not just for something generic
not just hey we just start on this
because this is what we do and if you
don't respond better it's your
responsibility for figuring out how to
do something different that's just one
example of where we're going to need a
lot of innovation healthcare reform has
to encourage innovation across the board
or else it's not going to succeed
I think innovation is going to be key to
health care and if you say to me what's
going to solve the health care problem
it's going to be innovation there are
different kinds of innovation there are
innovations in medical devices and drugs
and so on many of them add to expense
but they may improve health by quite a
lot there's another kind of innovation
that we haven't that doesn't get touched
on as much which i think is worth
highlighting which is innovation in the
way we go about providing medical care
there was an old TV show Marcus Welby
that probably the older listeners who
have seen in me and the younger viewers
will not Marcus Welby practice medicine
I think was the 1950s or so there is
nothing that is done in the medical
system today that Marcus Welby would
recognize no procedure no pills nothing
but he would completely recognize how
medical care is delivered it's a doctor
in an office with a patient and that's
what happens so almost nothing is the
same in the world today as it was in the
1950s accept the fact that we go about
providing medical care in the same way
let me just take one example of why that
is so harmful if you look at patients
with chronic disease diabetes or
hypertension or high cholesterol many of
them do not take the medications that
the doctor recommends because they don't
know what they're supposed to do or they
have side effects and they don't know
how to deal with them so very easy to
help them nurse practitioners can help
them physician's assistants that does
not have to be a doctor we do not pay
for that we do to recognize that we do
not allow that in most circumstances and
the result is that those people are not
treated well they wind up with
complications with very severe effects
afterwards and the whole system
dysfunction is poorly we need a health
care system that's focused around
helping the patient and if that means
that there's a nurse practitioner who's
there to help you out hey great if that
means that that there's a physician's
assistant or a group visit with lots of
other people figured out how to do that
then that's what we have to
able so far we almost prohibited we
don't help it we're not even neutral we
basically say we're not going to allow
that which is just a huge huge mistake
and it's something that's going to have
to be have to be very different or else
we're never going to make a lot of
progress
a lot of the innovations in health care
recently have come from a couple of
places one is the kind of analyst
community where there's been a wholesale
change in thinking since since the past
reform effort 16 years ago where you
know have much more attention
information technology and how you'd
eliminate waste and so on none of what
you saw and then the what's very
interesting is the provider community
has a number and ensure community for
that matter has a number of very
progressive elements groups that are out
there saying you know what we're just
not going to tolerate patients getting
substandard care care that's not as good
as it should be and so you have the male
clinics and the cleveland clinic's and
the kaisers and the group health
cooperatives and the health partners
this guy's into your health care's and
the Intermountain health care's and
Virginia Mason all of those examples
those are companies that said and their
insurance companies that provider groups
there dr. groups they said you know what
we are just not going to take it anymore
and many of them put themselves at
financial risk by doing better that got
in situations where they were preventing
readmissions to the hospitals enough so
that they nearly went under and some of
them had to go begging and pleading to
Medicare saying can't we work out some
arrangement where when we improve
quality and lower costs we don't suffer
so much and that's actually provided a
lot of the example that we have so it's
not when we talked to people now about
health care reform it's not hypothetical
it's real it's this works and we see at
work and you can have it too and I think
between the kind of analyst thinking and
what's going on at the most progressive
places you really have this this this
model out there and this framework for
what to do which is very very helpful
who parts have to go together the
covering people in the modernizing the
health care system you cannot do one
without the other in Massachusetts we
covered people without doing anything
about the cost we decided we wanted to
cover people first and we deal with the
cost later now we're stuck dealing with
the cost the system costs more than it
then we know how to finance just because
all medical care costs more than we know
how to finance so we've got to come back
and we're now trying to deal with the
cost in the national level people talk
about saving money first and then
covering people but nobody wants to see
the implications of a health care system
that tries to save money when they're 50
million people without coverage and
another 50 million people who are eating
out of coverage during the year would
just be an epic disaster so they have to
go together the key to it is has got to
be innovation
the u.s. is uniquely bad at some things
dealing with big social problems as an
area where we tend to be bad we have a
very pluralistic society people have
difficulty wrapping their minds around
it I think as I look at the debate I'm
hopeful and in part I'm hopeful because
I think most people have the best
intentions at heart so if you look for
example at many of the Republicans in
Congress you know I don't know a single
one who I've heard say gee it would be a
shame if everybody had insurance
coverage you know you don't see that
what you see are people struggling to
find an answer and the struggles are in
different sorts of ways now you know
people on the left and the right differ
about all sorts of matters they differ
about the proper role of government in
markets okay fine they differ about how
to finance things okay fine in the past
what's happened is that a lot of those
disagreements have overcome have
overshadowed the areas of agreement and
then you throw in some politics and some
reelection things and so on and they've
all come to overshadowing what we're
seeing this time is somewhat different I
think what we're seeing is people really
trying very hard to say i'm going to put
those aside and i'm going to try and see
where there's consensus and you know
they're actually following the president
who in his presidential campaign said
I'm going to gather everyone around the
table and I'm going to try and see where
we can agree about what to do this is a
very very hard policy problem it's
probably the hardest policy problem we
have today and what people are trying to
do is gather around and see can they
produce some consensus that really makes
sense and i'm somewhat hopeful that this
time we'll do it even if in the past
we've been unable to
you